hello i'm brian david gilbert and i'm a
person who makes
videos sometimes today i will be
answering 27 questions
[Music]
who is brian david gilbert that person
is me
i am one person who has three first
names
don't get confused some people do some
people call me david or just gilbert and
i respond to all of them
because i have no sense of self-worth
what is brian david gilbert doing now
that is a question
i have received from my relatives
multiple times
and i have not really figured out the
perfect answer to it
uh i'm making videos uh for my own
personal channel and i'm writing a bunch
of stuff on the outside
i also doing voice acting things
basically
um i'm a freelancer and i'm trying my
best to start saying that i'm
self-employed as opposed to
unemployed
does brian david gilbert have a twin
sadly
i do not actually have a twin i am a
single again entity if if there was a
real david brian gilbert out there
um i'd be i wouldn't i wouldn't be as
surprised
as i probably should be you know
what is brian david gilbert's favorite
nail polish color i'm going to grab it
for you real quick um
just give me two seconds my nail
polishes are always within reach
so i have uh i got two nail polishes
because i lied about saying that i only
have one favorite one uh one is called
terracopa and it's
um this kind of nice like bronzy shiny
one and then this other one is called
let's get digital
and it it looks super blue but it
actually goes on very translucent
and uh sparkly and it makes my nails uh
look like
iridescent beetle shells which is what i
like to go for
how tall is brian david gilbert um i
have said uh i'm five nine five ten on a
good day but
the truth is that i'm probably closer to
like five eight and a half
and i know this because i uh when i was
in high school and this should be a
surprise to know when i
was in chorus and i i went to all-state
chorus once and
in order to like figure out the risers
they would ask everyone to write down
um their height on it so that way they
could make sure that everyone was in a
in a row with everyone who was the same
height and that's when i learned that
all men
lie about their height because i uh put
down my actual height which is five
eight and a half and then i was put in a
row where everyone was
three or four inches shorter than me and
so i towered over
all of the other guys in the first row
who said that they were five nine
five ten felt very very proud of myself
and
seemed very out of place for uh that
specific riser
brian david gilbert bed yes
very much so yes correct
where did brian david gilbert learn to
dance uh i learned to dance
nowhere professionally my sister is a
trained dancer and she
taught me everything that i know that's
um somewhat
okay my older brother is not a
professional dancer or trained in any
way and he taught me all of the cool
dance moves that you could do
uh at weddings where like you pretend to
have a heart attack and then somebody
comes over and then
pretends to do a defibrillator on you
and you go
as you as you like go across the floor
and it's super uh it's a it's a crowd
pleaser do that at the next wedding you
go to
uh 14 years from now when the pandemic
is over
what's my favorite dance move well i
already uh admitted to the defibrillator
obviously but that one you can only do
once a year at most or else it gets
overplayed
um a big fan of uh here i just realized
that i'm wearing green pants
so this might be impossible to see i'm
just gonna blend into more
but i'm a big fan of this one where you
go like this it's a really
it's a really good one i like that one a
lot anything that really just
involves a lot of large big arm
movements
i'm a big fan of
are brian david gilbert and patrick gill
related we are not related
our last names are different names but
my older brother is also named patrick
um and that's mostly because there are
only
six names that white men have and they
are brian david gilbert patrick
michael and tom
dream character to portray
if they ever do a live action zelda and
i wouldn't
i wouldn't wish for this to happen but i
would love to play tingle
but other than that any villain really
any villain
any villain or tingle and perhaps those
are the same thing
[Music]
white wheat or rye i'm a big
fan of wheat i'm a big fan of
breads um that got seeds in them i like
to have a little texture in there
white bread if you can like squish the
bread and turn it into like
a play-doh-like substance not good
enough for me
[Music]
how do i like my eggs i'm a big
proponent these days of soft boiled
like popping them in for seven minutes
and then as soon as seven minutes is
over you put them in an ice bath for one
minute
and then you crack them open and then
you put a little cholula
and some salt and pepper and i eat that
for breakfast most mornings
because it's super easy and it's
delicious
game to have the biggest impact on
me there are so many games
it feels like a cop-out to say like
ocarina of time but that was like
such an important game to me in my
childhood and like growing up and
watching my siblings play it and then me
also playing it but being too young
and not being very good at playing games
at that point but that being said i also
think celeste
had maybe the biggest impact of my adult
life i would say
celeste was like it hit right at the
exact moment
when i needed to play that game um and
i will never stop talking about celeste
no matter how many times my
friends are annoyed by it
dream project whoo i mean
i flip between like wanting to go off
the grid
and open a pottery studio in western
arkansas
and never have to go onto the internet
ever again
and like writing for a tv show
so somewhere between those two things i
think would probably be my dream project
[Music]
morning routine i wake up and um
i've started streaming uh on twitch
while playing
video games and uh riding a bike because
i've realized that i never will exercise
if i
am not doing something else at the same
time to keep my mind off of it
i love to gamble don't you got something
to say about that
and for some reason playing a video game
and also streaming
and also riding a bike is just enough to
keep my mind
uh confused at all moments that i'm not
really aware of the fact that i'm
exercising
and i'm also not really aware of the
fact that i'm streaming and playing
video games
so it's a real big mess um but it's a
great way to wake up and really get
yourself started
[Music]
creative routine creative routine
usually what happens is that i get um
really stressed out about not having a
good idea
uh and then i say no brian just go and
take a walk and don't think about
anything and don't consider
any ideas and just you're just taking a
walk there's
no point to it just get out of the house
and be in the sunlight for a few seconds
and then usually somewhere on that walk
i go oh here's an idea of something i
could do
that feeling when you bite into a pickle
and it's not as
crisp because it the pickle is it's a
little squishy and then i come back and
i
write it and then i don't do any work on
it for four weeks and then i
uh film it and edit it in two days in a
blind fury and
that's that tends to be how it works
these days
[Music]
how many suits do i own too many suits
for for being a self-employed individual
now too many suits my like my dad had to
wear a suit to go to work every day and
i was like i
i want to have a job that doesn't
require me to wear suits and guess what
young brian you
did it you managed to get that job it's
called
sitting in your apartment all day in uh
sweatpants
and having in your closet
one two three four
five i've got a bunch of other jackets
i have a tuxedo how did i get a tuxedo i
have no
memory of how i managed to procure a
tuxedo
am i good at darts i would say that i am
better than average but i only say that
because i'm able to hit the dartboard
19 out of 20 times i'm not able to get
specific parts of the dartboard yet
um but i am able to hit the dartboard
now uh and not hit the drywall next to
it
which i would say again is better than
the average person
who never plays darts ever
what kind of voice would this have
no oh no
oh i don't even want to think too hard
about this
i'm honestly it's this voice that i'm
doing right now
is the problem is that i saw the face
and
it just naturally became this voice
and i'm so sorry
[Music]
uh biggest strengths i'm i'm
really good at soft boiling eggs now
i think has now become my biggest stre
the problem is that i have no concept of
like
things that are useful in the real world
anymore now that i've been
at home for 11 months so i i think my
biggest strength is definitely
cooking a really good soft boiled egg
and like
um i'm i'm really good at making
biscuits and gravy too
those are my two biggest strengths those
are the ones that i feel the most
comfortable about those are the ones i
might feel most confident about on a
daily basis
that i would be willing to brag about so
i'll say that those are my biggest
strengths weaknesses
uh physical
uh like illness wise
definitely weak also they're um
really bad at first impressions that's a
thing i've noticed is that
when i first meet people i'm very quiet
and i don't like to talk to them and
then
usually hopefully if they're willing to
give me a shot for like a month or two
months
then they i somewhat come out of my
shell and i become a little bit more
friendly and uh don't feel so
self-conscious all the time
but first impressions i am very bad at
how do i work with a team i was very
fortunate at polygon to work with really
lovely people that i
care a lot about and uh it helped me
feel much more comfortable talking
about creative ideas with other people
i'm really bad at putting stuff
down but i'm really good at like
bouncing ideas to the furthest extent
they could possibly go
and then once we've gotten to that point
uh backing it up into
a position where like oh this is the
actual good idea
so my job usually in a team
place is to throw as much clay
onto the pedestal
as possible and then hopefully
someone else will be there to help hone
it down into something that's that's
worthwhile
i can never open a pottery uh studio in
western arkansas if that's how i make my
clay metaphors
job experience um what i did not realize
that this was a full job interview uh
i started my first job uh technically
you know i did like
you know i mowed lawns for people and
stuff but that my like first
actual job was working at a climbing gym
uh and running birthday parties
and camps and that was my first ever uh
paid job and it was probably the best
one i will ever have for the rest of my
life
um and then uh i worked
as a copy editor for a terrible terrible
company in um baltimore for a bit and
then i worked for polygon
um and those are the important ones
how am i how's my problem solving skills
how's my problem-solving skills
apparently not that good considering it
took me a moment right there to
to switch between how are your
problem-solving skills and how is your
problem-solving skills it really it gave
me a major
moment of uh anxiety trying to figure
out how i should read this question
um uh pretty okay once i've calmed down
[Music]
why would i be the best candidate for
this position that's a great question
i i am a team player and i
you know i care a lot about the company
um and i think if you hire me i will
be able to make you know the the growth
rates
uh and the synergy of the company are
two things that i am really passionate
about um and if we can
really focus in q4 on the marketing team
i think we can see
great turnaround and great click-through
rates um
and and you know i also have six suits
so
i can i i you know have a different one
for each day of the week
i work six days a week
where do i see myself in five years oh
well if not in western arkansas then
hopefully somewhere equivalent
or better i think i i'd love to
[Music]
be doing something similar to this or
something bigger than this where i can
you know hopefully work with other
people and
make a big story that people connect
with
um and people can be passionate about
[Music]
do i have any questions for you uh
plenty i
would like to know what type of images
you're going to be putting on the green
screen behind me
um that's a very important question i
have uh i would love to know
um if there's anything else i can i
could do
in this uh question and answer session
to make this any easier for you
because you have a hell of an edit in
front of you given
given the responses i've given you you
have quite a lot
to go through
you can check me out on my own personal
youtube channel it's brian david gilbert
i have weird sketches
and of horrors i guess
a whole lot of stuff happens over there
and i can't um
be held responsible for it so feel free
to check that out if you're interested
i think that's probably enough